et
[Musique]
gg ne se débarrasser du marin shadow qui
courait après les shadoks de la lune le
marin le bateau et ses matelots sont
tombés dans l'eau que ceux qui craignent
pour la vie du marin et de semaad l'eau
sera super no shadoks maritimes ont été
spécialement étudié pour vivre on me
confie à l'intérieur des mers les plus
uniques
il trouve même cela très agréable et
fêter leur nouvelle demeure de très
joyeuses façon les sons si vous le
voulez bien nos joyeux matelot à leur
humide séjour pour faire un rapide tour
d'horizon de la situation extérieure
c'est avec un soupir de soulagement que
les shadoks de la lune avait vu le marin
tombé dans l'eau enfin ils allaient
pouvoir partir tranquille dans l'espace
à la recherche d'une planète plus
hospitaliers et non malheureusement
c'est peu courant car pour tout vous
dire la main d'oeuvre trompeuses et
shadox n'était absolument pas qualifié
pour ça
tout le monde sait en effet que pour
voyager loin à intersidéral mans parlant
il faut pomper autant et même beaucoup
plus avec la tête qu'avec les pieds et
la main d'oeuvre shadoks la valeureuse
n'était absolument pas musclé de ce côté
ce qu'il leur fallait d'abord et avant
tout c'était une bonne main d'oeuvre
intellectuelle et pour ça on allait la
soumettre la main d'oeuvre un régime
spécial sévère et accélérer à base de
calcul
concentré de culture générale sur
activer devons théorème fondamentaux
action pro ce tu l'as bien gras et
quantité de machin comme ça
intellectuellement très nourris ce sous
la direction du professeur charcot la
future main d'oeuvre interstellaire
shadoks pompe est intellectuellement et
les jbe depuis le temps qu'on en entend
plus parler
eh bien les jb les jbe ça n'allait pas
très très fort en réalité et si nous
avons laissé passé tellement de temps
justement son vous en parler c'est qu'il
se passait chez eux des choses assez
pénible que nous aurions préféré vous
cacher mais la vérité historique exige
que nous fassions notre devoir et nous
allons vous dira tout mais la prochaine
fois
[Musique]
m